you know I'm thinking about a slightly
different kind of example and that is
where our ego gets stuck because it
wants what it wants and it's not getting
what it wants mmm this is another way
that we can become stuck in it I'm
reminded of something that Winnicott
says this is not an exact quote but this
is the sense of it is that
psychopathology happens when we can't
make the transit from omnipotence to the
depressive position and the depressive
position is this rather obscure term for
this that was coined by Melanie Klein
the psychoanalyst but but it means to
reach a point where we recognize our own
helplessness that we give up trying to
control everything in our environment
and there's a way where the ego always
wants to control everything in its
environment and that desire can keep us
stuck and keep us from moving forward
and and I'm recalling early early in my
training process we were talking about
the transcendent function and I I was
saying you know is it like this and and
this great this wonderful analyst who
taught I think at least Deb and I her
name was Georgia Kelly she said nope
nope that's not it and then and I said
is it like this and she said no that's
not it
I said so is it like the depressive
position and she said yes and I I could
sort of Intuit what she was talking
about but I didn't have any language for
how those two concepts fit together but
I think I finally like 30 years later I
think I sort of understand it and and I
think it's that that sense of when
you're locked into an ego place of
wanting what you want part of what
happens is the ego has to surrender and
that surrender is what brings about the
possibility for renewal and growth and I
have a different kind of example to
share and it's rather involved so I did
get the the person's permission to share
it so this is a young woman she was
she was in her late 20s when this
happened and she was just trying to make
a career decision that involved leaving
where she was working she was working
overseas and she was wondering was it
time to stay or come back and in the
midst of it she'd fallen quite in love
with this colleague of hers and they
were dating and so for a little while it
seemed like that was great she was gonna
be with this guy they you know maybe
they would get married it was like she
wouldn't have to make a decision about
whether or not to leave the job and and
come back and then if she did come back
what was she gonna do was she gonna go
to graduate school but she gonna change
career she had all these kinds of career
things hanging but for a little while
which he was dating this guy it was like
oh great I don't have to think about any
of that and then she found out that that
his his ex-girlfriend wasn't really so
ex so it left her really hanging and she
just felt a lot of kind of I want to say
she felt a lot of like infantile rage
because not only was she upset I mean
kind of heartbroken
obviously but but also you know she she
could recognize that a lot of what was
so difficult for her about this
relationship rupture was that she was
now throw it back on herself and had to
deal with her own decisions she says
that she remembers standing at the
window at sunset looking looking out
watching the sunset and she actually
heard a voice and you know it wasn't it
wasn't a kind of psychotic hallucination
at all but it was a voice that said very
clearly you have to proceed with your
life as if this relationship isn't going
to work and it's not what she wanted to
hear right she wanted the relationship
to work she wanted the guy she wanted
all of our questions answered for her
almost that that really was an instance
of you know the self getting
constellated in this very direct way and
at an instant of the transcendent
function and and it was very sobering
for her she was like oh oh the way she
said it to me is oh I guess I guess I
have to take responsibility for my own
life don't I
and that that is also the depressive
position right it's when we're in this
infantile state you know it's like I I
want what I want give me what I want I
don't want to have to do anything I
don't want to have to know that I'm
responsible for my own decisions if
something doesn't work out I can get mad
at you but it was like it really just
landed for this young woman it's like
wow this is about me mm-hmm and I've got
to figure it out for myself